we fight to protect the peoples of the
south crisis on earth s crossover event
starts Monday November 27 hey everybody
we got our first teaser for the four-way
crossover let's freak out about this if
you're just finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's gonna be a whole bunch of
footage for this dropping really soon
too and there's new flash ring giveaway
stuff I'll explain at the end of the
video but since the footage is so short
I just wanted to do a quick video for
this just explaining what's going on and
what the timeline is and there's just
like a whole bunch of stuff that they
probably won't work into the teasers
like almost all the big characters have
alternate versions you may have seen
something behind the scenes pictures but
they just pick up with some regular
stormtroopers on earth X most of this
footage is either from Earth X or is
from STAR Labs as the team is getting
ready to go to Earth X we got the Holy
Trinity we got caity lotz and her newer
version of the white canary uniform
she's had that for a while but she
doesn't wear it that often and we also
have Alex from Supergirl so pretty much
every big character from all the four
shows will be a part of this and they're
billing it sort of like a four hour
movie so it's not like you just have a
couple characters crossing over to each
episode it's like everybody in every
single episode almost so it's very
different structurally from the way they
did it last year in the Supergirl
episode is a big part of that it's
taking place on two nights this is
actually what the schedule is the
dialogue from Oliver is just hyping up
the big fight that they have against the
earth ex-nazi versions of their
characters Supergirl is fighting someone
called over girl that's what Kara's name
is on her earth most of the characters
have evil versions of themselves except
for Barry because this looks like it's
going to be the Tom Cavanagh version of
the reverse-flash but they'll probably
be a slightly different explainer for
which reverse flashiest like maybe he's
a version of Harrison wells that became
the reverse-flash instead of being the
eobard thawne version hiding out in the
body of Harrison wells but it'll be fun
to see Supergirl Throwdown going up
against someone like over girl makes it
easier for her to not pull her punches
because she's so powerful like she and
Barry because of their power levels are
almost living gods on earth this is the
evil version of Oliver who's called the
grünfeld I don't know exactly what their
name for
is but green arrow in German is Grunfeld
so we'll see what his actual code name
is but he wears a special mask and if
you're wondering why they're wearing
masks is just because it's easier to do
the stunt work with the characters
fighting the evil versions of themselves
now Stephen Amell posted this teaser pic
of like oh you know can't wait to have
this scene been waiting for this for a
long time
it's probably him talking to the evil
version of himself while they're trapped
in the pipeline prison so scenes like
that they go back and forth but if
you're gonna actually like have a big
fight scene with the evil version of
yourself just put a mask on that evil
person so you could put whoever you want
to underneath it this looks like it
might be Sarah taking the Nazis down
anybody with really long blonde hair who
looks really live and as a badass is
probably Sarah but the graphic of the
outro just teases how crazy Earth X is
the reason why they call it earth X is
because it doesn't have a technical
designation it's not like earth 3 or
earth 4 or 5 it's called X because it's
literally such a burg everything
has gone so badly so the interesting
thing though about all this is that it's
Supergirl arrow then flash in legends of
tomorrow so I was really curious when I
saw that they moved arrow to be the
second part of the crossover so that
means that Oliver's gonna have a whole
bunch of scenes with Cara really early
on and in his last couple of livestream
videos he said you know sorry my voice
is hoarse I've been spending the last
couple of hours screaming at Supergirl
so as you would expect things go to
pretty fast but everybody just let me
know what you think about all this and
what are you hoping to see during it now
I know there's a lot of questions about
the other stuff that's happening like
obviously we know they fight the Nazi
versions of themselves
but the whole idea is is why would they
go there in the first place if the earth
is such a town then does one of the
earth X people come to our earth first
and does that set things off but
Supergirl is the first part of the
crossover so it sounds like if somebody
from the earth comes to a good
earth they come to Supergirl first she
finds out about it he then uses that
device that they gave her last year to
port to earth 1 so that she can get
Barry's help but if you don't remember
they did give Supergirl a device to open
wormholes so that she could by herself
come to different earths when she needed
to so unless
Cisco goes to get her that's how she's
getting back to the main earth to get
the other heroes hey Cara I made you
something what Cisco what what is it oh
it's it's an interdimensional
extrapolator oh it creates small
breaches so you can use it to cross over
to our universe anytime you need to
oh I also included communication
functionality so if you ever need any
help you can always contact the team and
remember if you guys ever need me I'm
just a call away
same here
[Music]
but there'll be a whole bunch of flash
stuff posting tomorrow we have episode
five Katee Sackhoff is debuting as the
blacksmith character so there's gonna be
an arrow crossover already so big
coincidence that they have an arrow
crossover and we also have the teaser
for the really big crossover but there
is a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on the
video
it'll just announce the winner when I
post my next flash video tomorrow
morning you can click here for brand new
flash and you can click here to learn
all about how Marvel might be crossing
over with the x-men in the Deadpool
movies Disney might be buying Fox thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight